I totally ruined my dynamite Napoleon
impression now what I'm working on Shrek
but it's years away I don't care
Jesus Christ you use talent that was
disgusting and I can't even concentrate
on that because I'm too busy hating that
dude I don't blame the guy though he's
cranky cuz he has to wake up so early
for swim practice you know what maybe we
need to make it so that he never ever
wakes up for swim practice again
neighbor's pool and they're just shocked
at Corinne my skin cut off finally red
and my hair straighten out for like a
month when I was a toddler actually fell
into a washing machine full of bleach
and I didn't get it you at all
I did die though for like four minutes
doctors said they couldn't believe how
much brain damage I didn't get they're
like really impressed I was fun you want
to do another story battle kicked your
ass no I just brought it up cuz I
thought we can maybe shock miss cool
good idea you should have just said that
now we're talking one of these has got
to do the trick
it's like sixty more back there man
alright
[Music]